thank you
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday September 15th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
as a Founder Trevor Milton was known for
making bold statements and displaying a
Charisma that inspired employees and
attracted investors when it came to
promoting his electric truck startup
Nikola he went on podcasts and news
shows making big claims about its
hydrogen trucks and the fueling stations
that would support them
the company brought in a lot of funding
and when it went public in 2020 retail
investors flocked to it raising its
valuation from 3.3 billion dollars to 30
billion
but now Milton is on trial accused of
lying about nikola's technological
capabilities to enrich himself he left
the company in 2020. Milton faces two
counts of wire fraud and two counts of
Securities fraud with the possibility of
25 years in prison he's pleaded not
guilty
beyond what it could mean for Milton and
Nikola the case could have Ripple
effects for other young pre-ipo
companies looking to get investors
excited about their future here to talk
about the trial and those potential
impacts is wsj reporter Ben Foley hi Ben
thanks for being here thanks for having
me so prosecutors allege that Trevor
Milton made these big promises and
misled investors about the technology
Nikola had developed can you tell us a
bit more about what those allegations
are and how they came about yeah so the
allegations came after a short seller
Hindenburg research and some
whistleblowers put out a report alleging
that Trevor Milton had made all kinds of
misrepresentations about about the
company and one of the U.S attorneys
when they first unveiled these charges
said Trevor Milton lied about basically
every element of the business and in
their opening statements the prosecutor
said Mr Milton had lied about the
technology that the company had built
namely kind of this early a prototype
truck which he had said you know it was
fully built fully functional and
whistleblowers and prosecutors allege
that no it wasn't never drove anywhere
under its own power and was rolled down
a hill for a promotional video that Mr
Milton misrepresented the production of
the fuel there were a couple times where
he'd said you know Nicola was making
hydrogen at four dollars a kilogram
which Not only was that kind of a
unprecedentedly cheap price for
producing hydrogen but Nikola had not
produced any hydrogen at any price at
that point they also kind of focused on
representations Trevor Milton made about
the quality and amount of the contracts
and orders they had for the trucks in
the future
and the last thing that they sound like
they're going to focus on in this trial
is a pickup truck called the badger that
was a big kind of motor for nikola's big
stock jump in June of 2020. but
prosecutors allege barely existed Beyond
some very basic kind of preliminary
steps towards it what do we know about
the defensive strategy yeah so Tuesday
was the first day that we really got a
look at it there were a few arguments
kind of running in parallel one was that
the government's case is based on
Distortion and they said kind of
distortion of context Distortion of the
words cherry-picking of claims they also
made the argument that it's not enough
to have misstatements you have to have
intent essentially and that Trevor had
not intentionally deceived and misled
they also pointed the finger at other
Nikola Executives according to them
Trevor was part of nikola's promotion
was kind of pushed to go out there by
Nikola Executives and not stopped when
he talked and you know made some of
these representations so there was kind
of a you know why isn't everybody else
at Nikola also being held accountable
for this and then there was also an
element of questioning the motives of
everybody who would be called to testify
against Mr Milton we got a taste of that
one of the witnesses
who you know acted as a whistleblower
has a financial incentive Under The
sec's Whistleblower program and also
participated in shorting the stock at
one point so it seems like you know the
defense is Keen to point out that people
testifying against Milton have an
interest in doing so they took kind of
an interesting tack at the end of their
opening statement Trevor Milton's lawyer
compared Trevor Milton talking about
Nikola as like a parent talking about a
child and said you know if a parent
looks at a five-year-old and says that
kid is going to Harvard nobody nobody
takes him seriously and thinks that that
kid is actually going to Harvard at that
moment and said that Trevor was kind of
talking the same way about this kind of
product of his labor and kind of a
vision for the future
let's dive into one of those points you
just mentioned Trevor Milton the founder
and former leader of this company is on
trial why isn't the company itself part
of this case I think if the defense has
their way the company will be a part of
this case looking as to kind of who in
the room was trying to stop Trevor
Nikola did settle with the SEC and had
an investigation into these allegations
and paid 125 million dollars so I think
Nikola the company did kind of pay its
pound of Flesh so to speak but even the
defense themselves kind of pointed out
was that Nikola and all of its
disclosures you know these kind of reams
and reams of financial documents would
often kind of have a more hedged or
careful or qualified version of some
statement and then Trevor would be the
one on the podcast or on TV with the big
boisterous claim let's talk a bit about
the people who did buy the Nikola stock
because a lot of them were novice
investors very excited about this
company is that expected to be an
important part of this trial at all I
think for the prosecutors it is they
really are trying to paint this as kind
of like this was a stock promotion scam
for lack of a better word that was aimed
at at retail investors and one of the
ways that they backed that up was by
saying that you know Trevor Milton
wasn't just you know on CNBC or just on
earnings calls he was tweeting he was
Instagram living he was you know validly
saying I want to be the most open and
accessible executive on on social media
and so according to the prosecution that
was kind of part of this larger fraud to
drive the stock price up by appealing to
retail investors and Robinhood Traders
and the like Nicola went public via a
special purpose acquisition company
sometimes called a blank check company a
lot of other green vehicle companies
went public kind of the same way around
the same time with also big promises
does The Fallout from Nicola have any
impact on them on how investors or maybe
Regulators are looking at them
I think Nicola was kind of the first big
SPAC success in the space and also the
first big catastrophic blow up in the
space and not the last of either of
those you know Nicolo in public in June
of 2020 it soared in its first week and
was briefly worth more than Ford Motor
Company without having any Revenue to
speak of and that kind of showed a lot
of companies I think that there was a
easier and quicker way of going public
pre-revenue in a lot of cases and that
the market had an appetite for those
kinds of deals at that moment
and really kind of drove valuations up
for a while so Nikola was the first of
those to kind of come back to earth with
these allegations that started coming
out in June but didn't really get
traction until September and then in the
time since a lot of the other EV
companies that have spacked have
disclosed SEC investigations or
Department of Justice investigations
they've been hit by short sellers you
know even the same short sellers in some
cases and the sector is really kind of
you know it's not just one Icarus it's
been a bunch of icari I guess Nikola was
kind of the poster child but they're the
whole sector has been kind of reacted
with these issues
all right that's our reporter Ben Foley
thanks so much for joining us Ben thank
you for having me and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing for more Tech
stories check out our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]